IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Hi, everyone.
I am Ibrahim Ulukaya from
YouTube API Developer Relations
team.
I am joining you
today from New York.
Today we'll talk about
the live streaming
implementation called XSplit.
And I'm sure if you guys are
playing games and streaming
them live, you are
already familiar
with this amazing
product XSplit.
But today we are really lucky to
have Henrik Levring and Miguel
Molina from XSplit to join us
and talk about the product.
Hi, guys.
Thanks so much for joining us.
HENRIK LEVRING: Good to be here.
Thank you very much.
MIGUEL MOLINA: Thanks.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: And today
they'll talk about the product,
and hopefully, we'll
see a nice live demo.
But to start, can you talk
about the history of the product
and what are the
goals behind this?
HENRIK LEVRING:
Yeah, definitely.
Well, originally,
SplitmediaLabs was really
organized as a development
team in a European--
a privately-owned outsourcing
company called World Partner.
The team started
off developing a set
of multimedia applications
for visual communication.
And the app that we
developed back then
was called XSplit Capture.
And that was really more of a
one-to-few video communications
product.
And that's the
product based on which
we got funding and
created SplitmediaLabs
as a company in Hong
Kong back in 2009.
This product is totally
different from how
XSplit Broadcaster is
today, and basically it
evolved from XSplit Capture.
XSplit Capture was only
published in an internal beta.
And from the
feedback we got there
and through the requirements
we discovered from users
and so forth, we sort of
changed it from a simple screen
capture with camera thing into
a real internet TV application
that we have today.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK, great.
Can you just show us a little
live demo of the product?
HENRIK LEVRING: Absolutely.
Absolutely we can do that.
So I"ll just boot
up XSplit here.
And probably some people might
note that it doesn't exactly
look like the XSplit
that they know,
and that's because the
new version of XSplit
that we're using
here for this demo.
So for those who
don't know XSplit,
XSplit has 12 scenes as you can
see here in the right corner.
And we've got input
sound and system sounds.
I can drag, as you can see,
an image to my first scene.
And on my second
scene, I'm going
to add StarCraft II, which I'm
playing in the background here.
So I've now got
two scenes set up,
and I'm ready to add my
YouTube Live channel.
I just go to the broadcast
menu at the channel
and then I just fill in my
credentials, Google YouTube
credentials.
And I need to authorize
first using the OAuth 2.0,
and just typing in my password.
So this all runs
from Google servers
and can take a little time, not
because it's Google servers.
And then, yep, we
got authenticated.
And we can add a
description, title,
and we can also
set our category.
These things we
can change as we go
live, but now we're done
setting up the channel.
So when we do go live now, you
can see the title bar changes,
and we get a prompt here.
So we can now select whether
we want to do an ad hoc event
or connect to an
existing scheduled event.
We can also change
our description tags,
and so forth, category,
just before we go live.
So consider the initial setup
as a template, so to speak.
So once we're live, then we've
got a link in our clipboard,
and we can try and test that
out to see if we're live.
And hopefully it's going to
show up in a short while.
It can take a little time.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
In the meantime,
can you talk about the new
features in the new product?
I assume that you guys have an
upload feature as well, right?
HENRIK LEVRING:
Actually, you can
see as I was-- some of the
features in the new product is
what we're seeing right here.
Once we hover our mouse
on the top of the scenes,
we can see a
preview immediately.
And that's definitely
one of the new features.
So anyway, now as you
can see, we got live
and I'm just going to
stop this broadcast now.
I'll just show you
another new feature here,
a very interesting thing,
which is our feature that
allows XSplit to upload videos
and track videos straightly
on YouTube.
So as you can see here
the preview-- that's
one of the features--
we're hovering a mouse
across the scene and
you can see the preview.
You can see what's behind
the scene, basically.
Right now you can see in scene
two my StarCraft was there.
So that's one of
the things that's
a brilliant thing with the
new version of the product.
So now I've made
a small recording,
and I can then go
to my recordings
where I can see the
recording I just made.
I can change the thumbnail view.
So this recording, I can
share it on Facebook,
Twitter and in Google+, but
first I need to share it
on YouTube.
I need to upload it to YouTube.
Then I can set my title and
my privacy settings there
and, I can straightly
go and upload it.
That also could
take a few seconds,
but our video's not
that big, so that
should be up in a few seconds.
We have to have a little
patience, perhaps.
So anyway, once it's up, we
can see here it has a link,
and we can just check it
out to see that it actually
got uploaded.
Well, it's being processed
but it certainly-- it'll
just take a minute.
It's there already, I think.
Yup.
So that's the video we just
recorded a few minutes ago.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: That's great.
HENRIK LEVRING: So
as you see there's
a small-- you can see a little
red thing in the video before,
and that was
uploaded to YouTube.
Now we're sharing
it on Facebook,
and we can share it on Twitter
as well and certainly also
Google+.
And these sharing
features all require
is that it's uploaded
to YouTube first.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: That's right.
HENRIK LEVRING: We
track the videos there.
So next time you
open XSplit, you
can see what videos
in my video recordings
that's already on YouTube.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Sounds great.
And thanks for
this amazing demo.
Can you just talk a little bit
about how this app implemented?
What programming
languages did you use?
HENRIK LEVRING: Yeah, certainly.
So all our core is built in
C++, because we have a lot
of functions that are very
close to the operating system.
So that's sort of what
we found most suitable.
And the UI and other functions
such as, for example,
the YouTube live broadcast
plug-in, is built using C#.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Was there any
reason that you guys used C#?
HENRIK LEVRING: I mean,
a lot of people know C#.
And it's easier, usually, to
develop interface using C#.
So I think that's why
we originally chose C#.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
Maybe, Miguel, talk
about if you guys used the APIs
through the client libraries
or just straight to the codes?
MIGUEL MOLINA: I think
I can answer that.
HENRIK LEVRING: Yeah, I
wouldn't be able to do that.
MIGUEL MOLINA: Initially we were
trying to implement it in C++.
But since when we started
our implementation,
the live API was
very much in beta,
and a lot of things
were changing,
so it was highly impractical for
us to keep rewriting our REST
code in C++.
So we just settled for the C#
client library that's provided
by you guys.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
Yeah, I should mention
that you guys were one
of the first implementers
first using the beta
version as well.
And by using it, can
you also talk about
if you're using other APIs
besides live streaming?
Because I saw you
were doing uploads
and you were also
tracking the videos.
MIGUEL MOLINA: Yes.
We are actually using the
data API, both Version 2
and Version 3.
We mainly use the Version 3 API.
But for tracking our
videos, such as tagging it
with developer tags, we have
to use the Version 2 data API,
because that's the only library
that supports developer tags.
But we do hope that you
will support developer tags
in the newer version.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah,
there's definitely
a request on that end.
We hope to have the developer
text on [INAUDIBLE] as well.
And besides that, can you
guys share any other feedback
or where you guys had
any surprise moments when
you were implementing this API?
MIGUEL MOLINA: Well,
back when we started,
we were actually surprised that
there was no live viewer count.
That was, I think,
early this year.
But it's already implemented
now in your latest release, so
[INAUDIBLE] with that.
And we were also surprised
with the way broadcasts
and streams were
kind of different,
because in our other use
cases, we just kind of stream
straight to an
endpoint, and that's it.
They have one end
point and then we
take note of that
and we stream to it.
But in your API, you create
multiple stream objects
and then you bind
them to broadcast
objects which are
the actual events.
And from what I understand
is, the stream objects to it
so that the end points
can be reusable,
and the settings are
very much preset.
So you can just select which
particular broadcast resolution
you're going to be going for and
then just bind it to an event.
I think that's
how you wanted it.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA:
Yeah, definitely.
You summarized it
for me already.
And are there any features?
Or do you guys want
to [INAUDIBLE]?
MIGUEL MOLINA:
Currently, I guess
we would like to enable
our broadcasters to be
able to interact with
our viewers more.
And to do that, you need
some sort of implementation
for your live comments.
But we also noticed a big delay
from the real-time broadcast
to the actual thing
that you see on YouTube.
So there's, like, a
40, 45-second delay.
And that would probably kill any
sort of real-time interaction
between viewers
and broadcasters.
HENRIK LEVRING: Yeah,
I think it's right.
I mean, the big
missing feature right
now is really low latency
and then real-time comments.
MIGUEL MOLINA: Yes.
HENRIK LEVRING: We see a lot
of the big streams in gaming
where, really, the broadcaster
feeds off the user's comments.
Do this, go there,
and they really
have a wonderful
interaction there.
And so we'd love to see that
on YouTube Live as well.
That's the biggest
missing feature, right?
MIGUEL MOLINA:
Yeah, I believe so.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Yeah, thanks
for the valuable feedback.
I'm sure, actually,
we are really
doing our best to get
latency lowest as possible,
and hopefully we'll
have comments in future.
And maybe like to summarize,
I heard, actually,
you guys also have
opportunities in XSplit as well.
Can you guys talk a little bit?
HENRIK LEVRING:
Yeah, absolutely.
So we're definitely
also hiring in XSplit.
You can go to
XSplit.com/careers.
And I think we have positions
open both for bus developers,
shop developers, web
developers, and so forth.
And our development center
is located in Manila,
but we're certainly
also accepting
applications from developers
from other countries, US,
and so forth.
So yeah, that'd be great.
Go to XSplit.com/careers and
see if there might be a position
you guys would
like to apply for.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: OK, thanks
so much for joining me today,
guys.
It was really nice
to see the live demo
and talk about XSplit
product, and I really
hope to see the new
features and the new version
publicly available really soon.
HENRIK LEVRING: It was
great to be here, Ibrahim.
Thank you.
MIGUEL MOLINA: Yeah,
thank you for having us.
IBRAHIM ULUKAYA: Thanks a lot.
And lastly, I just
want to finish up
with saying to the viewers
there's a Google Developer
Relations team.
We are hiring almost
everywhere in the world.
You can always check the options
from developer.google.com/jobs.
And thanks for joining
me today, guys.
And have a nice day.
Ibrahim Ulukaya from New York.